THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
>> Neil: THANK YOU, MY FRIEND,
VERY, VERY MUCH.
A REPUBLICAN IN TENNESSEE SITS
ON THE HOUSE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE AND JOINS US VIA
SKYPE.
ALWAYS GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
WOULD YOU MAKE ON THE
RESTRICTIONS ON THOSE TRAVELING
FROM BRAZIL?
I WOULD RESPECT WHERE MOORE
COULD FOLLOW.
WHERE ARE WE WITH THIS?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON THE
SHOW.
I THINK IT IS EXPECTED.
WE LOOK AT THE ACCOUNTS THAT ARE
COMING TO US FROM BRAZIL.
300 PLUS THOUSAND CASES.
THERE IS A UNIVERSITY DOWN THERE
AND IT PREDICTS THAT IT COULD BE
12 TIMES THAT.
THEIR ABILITY TO TRACK
INFORMATION IS DIFFERENT THAN
OUR ABILITY.
IF YOU DO 12 TIMES THAT ARE TEN
TIMES THAT, BEST 200,000 PLUS
DEATHS.
IT’S APPROPRIATE AND CONSISTENT
WITH THE PRESIDENT WOULD PUT
THIS RESTRICTION ON.
WE ARE WATCHING THEIR CURVE VERY
CLOSELY AND WATCHING THE CURVES
ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
IT IS APPROPRIATE AT THIS TIME
TO HOLD OFF ON NON-U.S. CITIZEN
TRAVEL FROM BRAZIL.
>> WE ALREADY KNOW THAT VISITS
FROM CHINA AND THE FAR EAST ARE
READY IN DANGER OF BEING CUT
DOWN AND VERY, VERY LOW.
DO YOU SEE ANYTHING TO CHANGE
THAT, OR DO YOU ADVOCATE SINCE
IT SEEMS TO BE THE WORST OF IT,
WE CAN ENTERTAIN ALLOWING MORE
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
OUR THINGS SO BAD THAT NOW IS
NOT THE TIME TO CONSIDER?
>> WE HAVE TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION EVERYONE’S CURVE.
WE’RE TREATING STATES
DIFFERENTLY IN NEWARK MERELY AS
A DIFFERENT PLACE.
I THINK WE CAN DO THAT IN TERMS
OF COUNTRIES OVERSEAS AND OUR
ALLIES AND FRIENDS.
WE WANT TO OPEN UP AS QUICKLY AS
WE CAN BUT IT REALLY DEPENDS ON
WHERE THEY ARE IN THEIR CURVE.
IF THEY ARE IN AN EXPONENTIAL
GROWTH PHASE LIKE BRAZIL IS, WE
PROBABLY NEED TO STOP TRAVEL.
>> DO YOU WONDER ABOUT THIS
RELATIONSHIP WE HAVE WITH THE
CHINESE?
THE ONE ISSUE THAT HAS COME UP
IS THE MORE THAT WE THREATEN TO
CRACK DOWN ON HOW THE CHINESE
ARE CRACKING DOWN ON HONG KONG,
FOR THE WORSE IT’S GOING TO GET
BETWEEN US CERTAINLY FINANCIALLY
FINANCIALLY.
THEY HAVE MORE REASON TO STICK
TO A DEAL.
THEY COULD CHANGE.
IT DOES GET OUT OF CONTROL.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> WE ARE ALREADY IN A GREAT
POWER COMPETITION WITH CHINA.
IF YOU USE THE DIAMOND PARADIGM,
WE HAVE BEEN IN ECONOMIC WARFARE
FOR CHINA FOR MANY YEARS.
WE DIDN’T EVEN KNOW IT.
THE CASE OF MOTOROLA IS AN
EXCELLENT EXAMPLE.
THEY SHARE THEIR IP INFORMATION.
THEY UNDERCUT THEM WITH
SUBSIDIES FROM CHINA.
IT IS SCRAPPED FOR $900 MILLION.
THAT’S WHAT FUELS OUR MILITARY.
THAT IS WHAT ALLOWS US TO
PROVIDE NATIONAL SECURITY.
IF THERE HAS BEEN A GREAT POWER
COMPETITION FOR A VERY LONG TIME
TIME.
IT’S LIKE IT IS GONE EXPONENTIAL
EXPONENTIAL.
IT’S INFORMATIONAL, CYBER
HACKING, ALL THIS STUFF.
THE WAY THEY’VE HANDLED COVID,
ONLY ICING ON THE CAKE TO A BIG
PROBLEM.
IF CHINA WANTS A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH UNITED STATES,
THEY HAVE TO START ACTING LIKE A
FRIEND.
THE WAY THEY HANDLED COVID IS
MORE CONCERNING.
THEIR RESPONSE TO OUR RESPONSE